and welcome everybody for the second
clarity of this workshop we will have
second office
he's what our talks that was mentioned
yesterday this would not be given by Ben
Rosen who is Toronto and well known for
his exciting work on hey well let me
first of all thank the organizers for
the opportunity to speak here so today
I'll be talking about some recent work
in circuit complexity on the sub graph
isomorphism problem and some corollaries
in finite model theory so here's kind of
outline of the talk I'll start by
introducing the sub graph isomorphism
problem I'll give some background on
circuit complexity and the connection
between AC 0 and first-order logic then
I'll discuss the main results which are
upper and lower bounds for this sub
graph isomorphism problem and we'll see
that this connection between AC 0
circuit size and the first order the
variable width in first order logic and
the tree width of the pattern G and for
formula size is a connection with
quantifier rank and tree depth so I'll
define all this as we go along and then
finally I'll discuss a really neat
connection between this circuit lower
bounds and a result in finite model
theory so let me start off by defining
the sub graph isomorphism problem and
I'll begin with two important examples
so the first is the K clique problem so
here K is some fixed parameter and we're
given as input a graph X and the
question is does does it contain a K
clique so a complete sub graph of size K
so the K clique problem is extremely
important in complexity theory so as for
its time complexity so this is a
brute-force upper bound of order and the
K simply by searching over all possible
K cliques somewhat better upper bounds
are known using fast matrix
multiplication you can get n to some
constant less than 1 times
okay but it's believed that into the
Omega K is really a lower bound for this
problem and if you could prove this for
all K or even for any growing sequence
of values K then you would separate P
from NP so it looks a very important
problem another example of a sub graph
isomorphism problem is the distance K
connectivity problem so here you're the
input is a directed graph X with
distinguished vertices s and T and the
question is whether s contains an ST
path of length K and this is also
important problem in complexity theory
so if we look at say the space
complexity of distance K connectivity so
the best known upper bound from savages
algorithm is order log K times log N and
it's believed that this is optimal so if
you could prove a matching lower bound
then you'd separate complexity classes L
and now okay so let me now introduce a
general sub graph isomorphism problem
the first I'll introduced a sort of a
uncoloured version which is maybe what
most people would mean by sub graph
isomorphism problems so you're we have
some fixed graph G and the input again
is a graph X on n vertices and the
question is does it contain a sub graph
isomorphic to G so by sub graph I mean
not necessarily induced sub graph and
I'll denote this by sub uncoloured of G
but the more important problem for this
talk will be the colored version of the
sub graph isomorphism problem so now we
imagine that we're given a graph X as
well as a coloring of vertices of x by
vertices of G and now we're asking if X
contains a sub graph which is isomorphic
to G via the the coloring and as well
see this is a much much more
well-structured problem okay and really
these two problems I introduced before
can be seen as special cases of this
colored sub graph isomorphism problem
where you're the pattern graph G is
either a complete graph or a path of
length K
so let me mention some reductions
between these problems so first of all
this is a very well known reduction from
the uncoloured problem to the coloured
problem by the so called color coding
technique in other words if you could
solve the coloured problem then you can
solve the uncolored problem with just a
small blow up in time for many graphs
gee these two problems the complexity
coincides so in particular when your
graph G is a core meaning that every
homomorphism from G to itself is
one-to-one the example would be if G is
the complete graph and one important
feature that the colored problem has
that the uncolored problem lacks well we
believe it lacks is that is minor
monotonicity so whenever your graph f is
a minor of G then there's a reduction in
fact a linear sighs monotone projection
from the F sub graph isomorphism problem
to the G sub graph isomorphism problem I
won't I'm gonna come back to this for
the end of the talk so let me not define
what a minor is now but just just to
mention that so this is a feature of
this problem that that will play an
important role later on okay so here's
the summary so far so this G sub graph
isomorphism problems are an important
and well-structured family of problems
as we'll see their complexity the
complexity of this problem is tied to
natural structural parameters of the
pattern G and determining the complexity
of this problem with respect to
different computational resources such
as time and space you know if we yeah if
we believe that this is in fact tied to
these parameters then we would separate
complexity classes P versus NP l versus
an L and so on okay so you know of
course there are many computational
resources that one could consider and so
for the rest of this talk I'm going to
focus on circuit size and formula size
so the next slides will give a sort of
overview of circuit complexity so
boolean circuits and formulas so by
boolean circuit I mean you know so we
have and or and not gates
sort of without loss of generality
nicely layers like this and we have our
inputs at the bottom and negations okay
so for purposes of this talk you can
think of circuits I so the circuit size
of a boolean function is this you know
the fewest number of gates you need to
compute that function and this
complexity measure of boolean functions
is essentially equivalent to Turing
machine time okay so there's an asterisk
ears is up to a polynomial factor and
ignoring uniformity but this lets us
sort of frame the P versus NP problem in
terms of circuits so we can think of P
as the class of problem solvable by
polynomial size boolean circuits NP is
the class of problems whose solutions
are verifiable by polynomial size poly
but you know I know okay so you know
ignoring uniformity so the holy grail of
circuit complexity anyway so a path to
showing peanut equals NP would be to
show that any problem in the class NP
for example the maximum clique problem
requires super polynomial circuit size
so in fact we believe that maximum
clique requires exponential circuit size
but sort of parameterised approach to
sort of the sort of minimal way that you
could get a super polynomial circuit
size lower bound would be to my proving
is sort of sequence of increasingly
stronger polynomial lower bound so if
you could show that K clique requires
circuits of size n to the Omega K which
we believe is the case for any
increasing sequence of case then then
you know even separate P from NP give it
unfortunately circuit lower bounds are
hard so this here's this is showing the
the sort of world record circuit size
lower bounds for you know explicit
functions in the class NP and as you can
see progress is quite quite slow so
they're currently the best lower bound
is only 5 n ok so so in order to even
prove super linear circuit lower bounds
we need to focus on weaker models of
computation
and for this talk that will mean
restricted classes of boolean circuits
is the one very nice restricted class of
circuits our boolean formulas so formula
is a tree-like search a circuit with the
structure of a tree in other words every
gate has fan-out 1 and intuitively
formulas are weak weaker model of
computation in that their memory list so
each the result of each sub computation
is used only once so we believe formulas
are weaker than circuits but this is in
fact sort of an open problem and this is
another holy grail in circuit complexity
this would be equivalent to separating
complexity classes NC 1 from P so the
challenge is to show that any explicit
problem in the class P such as SD
connectivity requires super polynomial
formula sighs ok and once again this
this sub graph isomorphism problems give
a nice parameterised approach to this
problem so if you could show that
distance K connectivity requires
complexity into the Omega log K for any
growing sequence of K then you would
separate and see 1 from P thank you
should I send the heavy complexity class
it's actually the non-uniform version
yeah for this overview that's fine it's
yeah ok so umm once again we're in
unfortunate situation that you know
formula size lower bounds are also quite
hard and so here's the world record
formula size lower bounds for explicit
functions in the class P and here at
least we have polynomial lower bounds
but we get stuck at cubic ok so this is
a similar situation and so once again if
we want to be able to approve
unconditional super polynomial lower
bounds we again need to focus on
restricted classes so sort of for the
rest of this talk I'm going to restrict
attention to a particular restricted
class of circuits and formulas known as
AC 0 and this is the this are boolean
circuits and formulas of constant depth
so you have just some constant number of
layers of and and or gates and of course
you allow unbounded fan into your day
okay Sikorsky you personally do we
believe that something can be done
because it's possible that all the
separations so for formula lower bounds
I am optimistic that we can I yeah I
wouldn't even wager to guess about
circuits yeah okay so I mean there are
other restricted models that one can
look at you could look at the monotone
case but here we'll be looking at
constant death
okay and what I'll show next is that so
AC zero circuits and formulas are an
interesting class in their own as Neil
mentioned in his talk yesterday they
model what you can do in constant time
with sort of polynomial in many
processors and they also have very nice
connections to logic so let me let me
explain that okay so there are close
connections between AC zero and
first-order logic okay so so there's
sort of two resource measures of
first-order formulas that we look at in
this talk so one will be the what I'll
call in this talk variable width so it
this would be the maximum number of free
variables in a sub formula so people
often talk of about the k variable
fragment of first-order logic so that's
that's what they mean so this is this
gives one hierarchy within first-order
logic yes this would be the same thing
as you know you're only have K variable
names in your in your sort of vocabulary
and you're allowed to reuse variable so
that would be fo superscript K I really
like this is a more elegant definition
so you don't have to reuse the variable
if you haven't seen this before yeah
maybe anyway it's a puzzle equivalent
and another another sort of complexity
measure first-order sentences its
quantifier rank so this is the nesting
depth of the quantifiers in your formula
okay and so these have very nice
connections with with AC zero so here's
the kind of basic theorem so you have a
first-order sentence fee so the model
checking problem for fee is the
following problem you're given a
structure with universe 1 to N and you
want to know is a a model of fee
so the basic theory is that this is
solvable by AC 0 circuits of size order
n to the variable width and this is
essentially an exercise you just you
know each existential gate you make a
big and or gate and okay so the
observation here is that so the depth of
the circuit well you're only going to
have quantifier rank many layers of of
unbound of the big fan and gates and but
those will all have fan and n because
you each quantifiers quantifying over
you know the universe of size n so if
you were to take these circuits and
transform them into formulas by just
making them tree-like then well so the
formula size is sort of bounded by depth
times fan in so we can also say that the
model checking problem is solvable by
ac0 formulas of size n - the quantifier
rank so this is the connection between
circuit size and variable width and
formula size and quantifier ring and of
course quantifier rank is always at
least variable with formula size is
always at least circuit size
just briefly to mention you know another
kind of resource hierarchy within within
first order logic would be you know sort
of with respect to the background
relations so you could allow and you
know so you a vanilla first order logic
and since we're always talking about
finite structures with universe 1 to N
you could also consider the setting
where you have in the background a
linear order or a bit predicate or even
arbitrary relations which sort of
corresponds to non-uniform AC 0 so let's
get to it so it was hinting at this this
distinction before so if you look at
first-order logic with a bit predicate
in the background and so there's nice
results and descriptive complexity is
show that this corresponds to uniform AC
0 and but for what I'll be talking about
really we our lower bounds at least will
apply to the non uniform AC 0 which
corresponds to first-order logic with
arbitrary background background
predicates I don't want to say too much
more about about this ok so just the
takeaway from this part of the talk we
have the following so here's how you can
get results and lower bounds and logic
from lower bounds and circuit complexity
so lower bounds for AC 0 circuit size
translate into lower bounds on the
variable width the number of variables
you need in first order logic with
arbitrary background background
predicates and lower bounds for AC 0
formula size give you lower bounds on
quantifier rank
okay good so now let's get back to to
the the main subject of our talk this
sub graph isomorphism problem so I'm
going to present both upper and lower
bounds for this in terms of these
natural structural parameters of the
graph G so let me start by showing you
what are the upper bounds okay so so
like the the theorem I yeah I don't know
if anyone knows what the attribution for
this let me know but so it's not hard to
show that this G sub graph isomorphism
problem is the definable by first order
sentence with tree with +1 variables and
as well as by first-order sense with
tree depth quantifier rank so I'm going
to define what these tree with and tree
depth are next but you know and moreover
do this with first-order expressions
which are existential and positive and
yeah if you translate these first order
formulas into AC 0 circuits and formulas
you you get AC 0 circuits of size tree
with and formulas of size into the tree
dance ok so let me let me define things
a bit so so tree width of a graph G is
defined in terms of a notion called a
tree decomposition so here we have a
graph G and the tree decomposition of G
is a tree whose nodes are labeled by
subsets of the vertices of G such that
some condition holds if you look at any
vertex here or I guess every edge
belongs to some some bag here and the
set of nodes of the tree which contain a
given a given vertex such as B is a
connected ok so this is a tree
decomposition and tree with is defined
as the essentially the size of the bag
you need here minus 1 the definition
actually isn't really so important for
the talk just to mention so that if you
have a tree any tree has tree with one
and the
pleat graph has tree with K minus-1 and
to see to get the upper bound for sub
graph isomorphism you note that if you
have any width K tree decomposition for
G it kind of gives a blueprint for a k
plus 1 variable first order sentence
which defines the G the presence of a G
sub graph this is more or less easy
exercise okay
as for tree depth this may be a somewhat
less familiar notion to people so so let
me first define the notion of the
closure of a tree so T here is a finite
rooted tree and the closure of T is the
graph formed by adding edges between all
ancestor descendant pairs in the tree so
in other words you put it click along
every branch of this tree so that's the
closure of a tree and the tree depth of
a graph G is the minimum height of a
tree T such that G can be realized as a
sub graph of the closure of T so just to
illustrate this with the zip was the
tree depth of complete graph let's say k
4 is 4 because it's it's actually equal
to the closure of the path of length
with order for the complete bipartite
graph K 3 3 this is showing that well
it's actually I guess the closure of
this graph here and for paths that tree
depth is logarithmic in the order so
this is showing that P 7 here is a sub
graph of the closure of the complete
binary tree of height 3 so there's some
just to mention some relationships
between these parameters so the tree
depth is always at least the tree width
and at most the tree width times log
number of vertices and also this it's
sort of exponentially related to the
length of the longest path in the graph
G
and similar similarly to what we had
before so if I give you a height K tree
such a G is a sub graph of its closure
this you could take this as a kind of
blueprint for a quantifier rank K first
order sentence which defines the G sub
graph problem so it's as easy exercise
to sort of show that this is giving us
yeah okay so let me now state the main
results of the of the talk which are
going to be matching lower bounds for
for a see zero sense so these are the
two main results that I'll say something
about in the in the rest of the talk
okay so the first is that so this is
joint work with yuan li and Alexander as
brav so the result is that the AC zero
circuit size of the G sub graph
isomorphism problem is n to the Omega
tree width so this is really tree with
over log tree with I'm just hiding the
log factor okay so this is you know
almost matching the end to the tree with
upper bound okay oh and the second
result which is which is in recent joint
work with Kenichi core obayashi we get
similar matching lower bounds for the
you know AC 0 formula size of sub G we
show that this is n to the Omega
poly-tree depth so tree depth to some
fixed constant epsilon over all this for
all graphs for all fixed friends right
okay and so these both of these results
sort of extend special cases which which
for which I showed in previous work so
so this this result here is sort of
generalizing the technique of my earlier
work which shows that the K clique
problem has a seasonal circuit size n to
the Omega K and this theorem here is
sort of building on earlier work which
shows that the distance K connectivity
problem has AC 0 formula size n to the
Omega log K so these are both sort of
special cases
so the as corollaries and logic via this
connection that i described earlier it
follows that the the sort of variable
width of sub G is Omega tilde of the
tree tree width and the quantifier rank
you need to define sub G is polynomial
in the tree depth even with arbitrary
background predicates okay so this is
just translating translating these
circuit lower bounds into this into the
kernel logic each each of these also
kind of resolve questions which had been
asked in finite model theory so a sort
of corollary of this result even just
for cake like this shows that the
variable hierarchy is strict over
ordered graphs so this has been an open
question and sort of an interesting
corollary of this result which came as
rather a surprise to me that this gives
a new proof of this homomorphism
preservation theorem on finite
structures and in fact with with them
with a much better parameters and so
I'll get to that at the very end of the
talk so just to explain what where does
this coming from so sort of corollary of
this results of the cake list problem of
course it's definable with just K
variables you don't need any background
predicates but what this result shows is
that on ordered graphs or even sorry I
mean with a linear order in the
background or even arbitrary background
predicates you need at least K over 4
variables so this shows that the
hierarchy is I guess non collapsing and
then a very nice observation of the
elimin showed that that implies that the
variable hierarchy is strict on ordered
graphs
ok so I'll tell you you know on the rest
of the stock oh say something about the
proofs of both of these results so let
me start with the how we prove this
result here
and the proof uses a probabilistic
method so what we really show our
average case lower bounds with respect
to particular input distributions so
you know random input graphs which are
sort of generalizations of the
erdos-renyi random graph and I won't say
too much about the actual proof
technique but I want to tell you what
the sort of hard on average input
distributions look like and how they're
related to the tree width okay so let me
say something about that and let me
start off by talking about what's the
average case for the uncoloured sub
graph isomorphism problem and here this
there's a very natural distribution of
input graphs to look at which are the
air dish Raney random graphs so here
just rainy NP so this is the random
graph where you have n vertices and for
each pair of vertices you put an edge
independently with probability P so so
for every fixed graph G there's some
threshold value for the appearance of G
sub graphs so I mean here if you plot
out I mean here's this edge density P
and then the probability that the random
graph contains a sub graph isomorphism
to G this is an increasing function so
there's some unique threshold value
where this probability is exactly 1/2 so
that would be a very natural random
input to look at and sort of remarkably
it turns out that for many graphs G so
in particular for the for the K clique
problem the the random graph at the
appropriate threshold turns out to be a
source of or we believe it's a source of
hard on average input distributions so
yeah it's sort of a remarkable
phenomenon so what's the average case
now for the colored sub graph
isomorphism problem and now there's no
longer one canonical choice of sort of
product distribution which which you
could look at but rather we sort of get
a family of input distributions which
you might call G colored here just rainy
random graphs so it kind of gonna allow
a different edge probability for each
color class for each pair of color
classes and there's a really nice
characterization of what the Thresh what
it was a threshold for these random
graphs so let me just tell you
okay so I mean so it's conjectured that
- okay so let's just talk about the
uniform random graph G n 1/2 so we know
that you know almost surely the largest
clique has sizes roughly to log in but
it's a it's a very big open problem
actually raised by carp to find a clique
bigger than one you know bigger than log
n so bigger than half the expected size
so we believe that this is you know hard
hard instances for the quick problem so
the there's no expected comment right
yeah
okay so as I mentioned we're going to
the ideas we're going to allow different
edge density for each for each pair of
color classes in the in these colored
random graphs and the question is what's
a sort of threshold family of these
densities so there's a really nice
characterization of this class yes I'll
show in a second I'll show in a second
yeah so let me introduce a notion which
I'll call a threshold waiting for a
graph so so a threshold waiting is so
for each edge in the graph we have a
function beta which is assigning a value
between zero and two and we'll say that
this is a threshold weighting if it
meets two conditions so the first is
that for any sub graph of G if you look
at the the sum of the edge weights in
that sub graph it's it's at most a
number of vertices in the sub graph and
the second is that this this inequality
isn't it holds with equality in the case
where f equals G so in other words the
sum of all the edge weights in the graph
equals the number of vertices in the
graph so here this is an here's one
example you add these four edge weights
we get four which is the number of
vertices but you know if you look at any
sub graph the sum of the edge weights is
always at most the number of vertices
there's a really nice alternative kind
of characterization of this class which
comes from Markov chains on the graph G
so Markov chain you have sort of
transition probabilities supported on
the edges of the graph which you know
the transition probabilities coming out
of any edge sum to one okay so for any
Markov chain supported on the graph this
and this is a threshold weighting by
just taking the sum of the transition
probabilities in the two directions on
the edge and and so yeah every every
threshold weighting can in fact we
realized that by some Markov chain it's
not one-to-one but this is another okay
and here's the connection between so for
yeah so just to mention briefly now
there's a nice connection between these
markov chains on a graph and tree width
so just to say this somewhat informally
but so if for any graph G with tree with
K there exists some set of vertices of
size Omega K and some Markov chain on G
that concurrently routes one over K log
K flow between all pairs of vertices and
s the precise meaning of this statement
isn't is not not terribly important that
just to point out that somehow this is a
kind of dual certificate of having large
tree with is always the existence of a
certain kind of flow concurrent flow or
Markov chain on the graph and we're
going to use these as the construction
of our of our good threshold weightings
so let me now define so for any
threshold waiting beta we get a G
colored random graph which I'll denote X
beta this in the following way so we're
going to create invert a cloud of n
vertices for each of the vertices of G
of G and then we put edges you know for
every pair of edges between a color
class we put an edge you know
independently with probability n to the
minus beta of the edge okay so that the
random graph might look like this if
beta was one then you get something
which looks more or less like a random
matching so these are the random graphs
corresponding to the threshold wings
okay so just yeah these have a lot of
really nice properties so justifying the
terminology threshold weighting you can
show that this X sub beta the
probability that it contains the G sub
graph is bounded away from 0 and 1 and
you know moreover in sort of nice cases
where G is connected and this beta is
strict in some sense that you know the
number of G sub graphs is asymptotically
for some and there's a nice really nice
expression for the you know number of f
sub graphs in here for any sub graph F
of G okay this isn't terribly important
but we use all these facts about about
this random graph in the in the lower
bound okay so yeah I'm not gonna wait
too much into details of how we prove
this but just to show this kind of scale
here so okay so the result is that AC
zero circuits for the G sub graph
problem require size n to the Omega tree
with over log tree with so they're gonna
three steps so first is we define some
constant C of beta associated with each
threshold waiting beta okay then we sort
of the main the main result in some
sense is we show that the average case
AC zero circuit complexity of the G sub
graph isomorphism problem with respect
to this input distribution is really
characterized by this constant C of beta
so we get actually both upper and lower
bounds so a lower bound of n to the C of
beta and an upper bound of n to the to C
of beta so this this parameters is
really characterizing the average case
complexity and then the the third step
is showing that for every graph G there
exists some threshold waiting with the
property that this C of beta is at least
you know the tree link over long tree
with okay now if you combine these yeah
steps two and three or the lower bound
from here and then step three then we
get our theorem okay so that's that's
how this goes and yeah and of course
this bait is coming from this this
Markov chain that that's a kind of
certificate of having large tree with
okay so yeah now I'll say something
about the second results of this lower
bound on the AC zero formula size in
terms of the tree depth so let me remind
you of the definition of tree depth so
recall that the tree depth of a graph G
is the minimum height of a tree T such a
G can be realized as a sub graph of the
closure of T so we're now going to
really exploit this minor monotonicity
of the colored sub graph isomorphism
problem so I mentioned this earlier but
let me say it in somewhat more detail
now so first of all what what is a minor
of a graph so here we have a graph G so
a minor of G is any graph you can obtain
from G by first you can throw away some
vertices of edges and then you can take
sort of disjoint connected sub graph in
G and contract them into single vertices
so this is showing that you know this F
is heinous as a minor of G so whenever F
is a minor of G there is a reduction
from the F sub graph isomorphism problem
to the G sub graph isomorphism problem
this is a fairly easy exercise and these
reductions are actually so this it's
really a linear monotone projection in
fact from this problem to this problem
okay so that means that the complexity
of this F sub graph isomorphism problem
is always at most the complexity of the
G sub graph
okay so so these parameters tree with
and tree depth
have the nice property that they're
monotone with respect to this graph
minor relation so if F is a minor of G
then the tree width of F is always and
most the tree with of G and similarly
with tree depth okay and so there's this
this celebrated robertson see more graph
minor theorem shows that you know every
my every minor closed class of graphs is
characterized by a finite set of
excluded minors so in particular if we
look at the class of graphs G with tree
depth at most K for any constant K this
is characterized by some finite set of
obstructions but it's known that that
the size of this set is doubly
exponential and they're at least doubly
exponential as a function of K so so the
question is well suppose we only want to
approximate tree depth so we want a sort
of set of obstructions which give which
give an approximation of tree depth can
we get away with some sort of fixed set
would you know which is independent of
independent of K in some sense so just
for example if you recall earlier in the
talk I showed that the tree depth is
sort of exponentially related to the to
the length of the longest path so log of
the log of the length of the longest
path is always at least the tree depth
which is always at least they're sorry
at most the length of the longest path
so so the longest path is sort of an
exponential approximation to treat tree
width and this is really just you know
one plus the largest excluded path minor
so if you just look at path excluded
path minor that's giving you some
approximation but it's only exponential
okay and what we're going to want for
our result is a polynomial approximation
with Trena so so in the case of tree
width this was accomplished actually
recently by this you know
polynomial grid Meyer theorem of chicory
and Josiah so the result is that every
graph with tree with at least K to some
fixed constant contains a K by K grid
minor okay and moreover the K by K grid
minor has tree with K so this is showing
that the set of grid miners so the
largest grid miner is a in a graph is a
polynomial approximation of its tree
with o so a K by K grid so the law you
want to know the largest K such that the
K by K grid graph yeah it's a minor of
your in C depends on what no C is a
absolute constant in their proof it was
I think 86 it's known that the best it
could possibly be as to so you this will
never be a linear so there's will always
be a polynomial approximation but yeah
and I mean I guess I should say that so
you know the original grid minor theorem
of Robertson and Seymour had some
exponential bound here in terms of K and
so this has been a big open problem in
the this graph - in fact it does so
their result in fact gives a polynomial
time algorithm which finds the right
but no I guess okay I know that it's
effective in some sense i I don't I
don't want to say something too strong
but I believe it does give so I yeah so
promoters I don't care about the whether
or not this is effective in fact in all
result it won't be effective so yeah
I'll see in a second but I would have
point out a corollary of this grid minor
theory so we could use this grid minor
theorem to prove a lower bound on the
eighth circuit size or AC zero circuit
size of Sub G for all graphs G and V the
following observation I mean so if you
could prove that the sub graph
isomorphism problem just with respect to
K by K grids has circuit size into the
Omega K for all K then via this grid
minor theorem and the minor monotonicity
of the graph isomorphism problem it
would follow that the G sub graph
isomorphism problem has circuit sized
into the Omega tree with to some epsilon
epsilon is 1 over C in fact for all
graphs G okay similarly you could put a
C 0 here in here ok and and if you did
that that would be yeah so this is not
that this is weaker than what we
actually prove for a C 0 we proved true
with over long tree with but this would
be another way of getting at least this
repair so this is the strategy that
we're going to use to get our lower
bounds in terms of tree depth okay and
so this took you know new result in kind
of graph miner theory so and this can be
seen a sort of analogue sort of tree
depth analog of this polynomial grid
minor theorem ok so I guess you could
call this a quota grid tree path miners
theorem so this is joint work with Kenny
Chikara bye ashie
so the result is the following that
every graph with tree depth at least
kate is some constant C contains one of
the following three miners so either a K
by K grid
or a complete binary tree of height K or
a path of length 2 to the K okay and
each of these graphs has tree depth at
least K so therefore this these three
obstructions are giving a polynomial
approximation of the tree depth of G
okay so in other words you know to
compute the exact obstruction sets the
tree depth is seems like a hopeless task
there you know doubly exponentially many
of them but if you only want the
polynomial approximation of the tree
depth then you only you know these three
classes of obstructions suffice that's
what this result says okay and similarly
so we you know as a corollary here if
you could show that the sub graph
isomorphism problem for these three
graphs has a c0 formula sized into the
Omega K for all K then as a consequence
that the G sub graph isomorphism problem
would have a c0 formula size into the
poly tree depth for all graphs G in the
same way okay and this is what we do so
that we we have these three cases so the
grid case in fact follows from the
previous work of with with Lee and
raspberr off simply because the K by K
grid has tree with K so it has a c0
circuit size n to the Omega K so
therefore it has a c0 formula size at
least that the case of the path this was
shown in this previous work which I
mentioned so this is really the distance
2 to the K connectivity problem so this
was in this previous work and then the
sort of only new ingredient is sort of
extending this similar proof idea to
work for the for the complete binary
tree of height K okay this is
unpublished this is this is upcoming
work and yeah I guess I should mention
this so this this here was published as
a sick dog column recently but it will
be appearing in the next itcs okay
so there so and yeah it's these results
we should give this
so the AC zero formula size of the G sub
graph isomorphism problem is into the
poly-tree depth so in the kind of last
part of the talk let me tell you about
the sort of surprising corollary of that
result in finite model theory so this is
giving us sort of stronger or what I'll
call poly rank version of the
homomorphism preservation theorem on
finite structure so yeah I guess I have
I have some time so I'll try to go
slowly here so let me get the background
some of the background for this result
so so here are three classical
preservation theorems and here I'm
talking this is sort of purely model
theoretic result no assumption of finite
structures here anything so so these
these here three therms so the bow
starts keep their Linden's theorem and
the preservation theorem which
respectively say that if a first order
formula fee is preserved under injective
homomorphisms surjective homomorphisms
or all homomorphisms well so if and only
if it's equivalent to a formula which is
existential positive or existential and
positive okay injective he really should
be embedding but so these are results
which which sort of characters say that
a certain semantic property of a
first-order formulas is equivalent to a
syntactic property so you know one of
the sort of early directions of research
and finite model theory was exploring
which theorems of classical model theory
survive when the statements are
restricted to finite structures and some
some of the first results in that
direction we're showing that these
preservation theorems fail on finite
structures so the there are counter
examples to the bow Starsky and Linden's
theorems due to Tate and I tiger ravish
so these come to examples show that so
there exist first order formula which is
preserved under objective or subjective
or morphisms on finite structures yet is
not equivalent on finite structures to
any existential or respectively positive
formula
and in fact yeah there's a sort of you
know these the I Tanqueray pitch they're
really it's even in a stronger form with
respect to non-uniform AC zero circuits
so this is showing that the syntactic
class of monotone AC zero circuits is
not equivalent to the semantic class of
AC zero circuits which compute monotone
functions so syntax is different from
semantics with respect to monotonicity
in AC zero and I guess I thought I had
it on the slides but I guess I don't I
so yeah I should have mentioned earlier
that so this the proof of this result
you know use the compactness theorem a
first-order logic and the compactness
theorem fails in finite setting so the
so an early result of mine sort of
before I was working in circuit
complexity was showing that sort of con
you know in contrast to the [ __ ] are
scheming dense theorems this
homomorphism preservation theorem turns
out to survive on finite structures so
the result is that if a first order
formula fee with quantifier rank K is
preserved under homomorphisms on finite
structures then it's equivalent on
finite structures to an existential
positive formula of quantifier rank F of
K first where F is some computable
function okay so it's computable but
it's a very very bad function so this is
actually a non elementary upper bound on
the quantifier rank blow-up okay now in
the same paper we actually prove that
well in the infinite so we also give a
new compactness free proof of the
homomorphism preservation theorem via
sort of a constructive method which
actually shows that you have no
quantifier rank blow-up in the infinite
setting so I call this the echo rank
homomorphism preservation theorem but
you know it's a formulas it's a first
error formula fee is preserved in normal
morphisms and it's equivalent to an
existential positive formula with the
same quantifier rank so so there was
this big gap in on the finite setting we
had a non
entry upper bound and then in the in the
classical setting we have the exact same
quantifier range so this is a this is a
question that had been open from from
from that so the the the new results are
the improvement that we get we actually
using our lower bounds formula ec0
formula size of sub graph isomorphism
we're able to show a polynomial upper
bound on the quantifier rank blow-up in
the finite homomorphism preservation
theorem yeah so that's the so the the
yeah and the proof is via it's really
it's not it's not that that complicated
but it gives a reduction to the to this
formula size lower bound as I mentioned
just a few few other comments on this so
using just the lower bound for distance
K connectivity due to the fact that the
length of the longest path on a graph is
an exponential approximation of the tree
depth if you only appeal to this lower
bound then you would get an upper bound
on this quantifier rank blow-up of
exponential in K and if you take the
simple reduction and in fact you you
appeal to a low you know the very first
ac0 circuit lower bound for the distance
K s the connectivity problem due to I
tie an 89 then you actually get also a
non elementary upper bound
but the point is that actually if if I
if I ty had noticed this simple
reduction way back in 89 then the home
office of preservation there would have
wouldn't have been an open problem when
I got around to thinking about my time
misses a few things that dementia that
actually was that so okay if you use in
in our theorem as I stated it looks like
we're using the grid minor theorem so
you you'd incur there confident and
you'd get some 86 or something like that
in fact in the real result the the great
case is really a tree with case so the
so it's really something like five or
ten or something like that but I mean it
should be I you know I suspect it should
really there should be no blow-up but I
with the former size no yes I believe
that the tree depth sorry yeah I
strongly believe that end to the tree
depth is the true lower bound and in
fact I should mention that not only for
AC zero circuits but from so not only
for AC zero formulas but for a general
boolean formulas it's just that the
proof technique you know somehow uses
the fact that we're in the constant
depth regime so in addition to this
quantitative improvement I should
mention that there's also the the route
via circuit complexity gives a sort of
qualitative improvement that actually we
kind of get a non-uniform circuit
version of the homomorphism preservation
theorem and this is also in contrast to
the like I tiger ravaged so result which
showed that syntactic monotonicity is
different from semantic monotonicity
with respect to AC zero well here we
show sort of that well syntactic well so
the semantics class of homomorphism
preserved graph properties that are
definable in AC zero coincides with the
sort of syntactic class of existential
first-order logic which isn't which is
contained in polynomial sighs monotone
DNF formula so just deputy formula so
so what happens to uniformity here this
is non yeah this is even non-uniform
this is just what you think it means
this isn't circus yeah I mean yeah
there's no there's no matter what is
this what is this in tactically
homomorphism preserved AC zero circuit
so monotonicity is a nice thing because
it's just no negations man so anyway but
you know the sort of takeaway is that if
you look at take this powerful class
non-uniform AC zero and if you restrict
to just the homomorphism preserved
properties the miss class collapses to
you no uniform polynomial sighs monotone
DNF so it's a you know this question of
syntax versus semantics you know we had
all these counter examples but you know
maybe there's some evidence that we you
know at least for very strong property
like homomorphism preserved that these
things actually coincide so here's the
yeah that last slide sort of summary so
we introduced this sub graph isomorphism
problem this nice family of problems and
show that so its complexity is tied to
natural structural parameters of G and
two fundamental questions and complexity
theory P versus NP l versus a now and
yeah so we went over this nice
connections between AC zero and
first-order logic and sort of the maybe
main takeaway is that AC zero circuit
size is related to the first-order
variable width which is related to the
true width of G and formula size is
related to quantify a rank and treat
that and yeah I showed you that for this
colored problem there's this really nice
natural family of input distributions X
sub beta and it's sort of remarkably
yeah for sort of optimal choice of beta
this sort of turned out to be sort of
hard on the average so yeah that's
that's the last lie I you know I never
know how how much ground I'm gonna be
able to cover so I prepared a few extra
slides after the thank you which maybe
maybe I have time to show a little bit
of want to get out early but um yeah
yeah okay maybe I'll end it here and we
can pick up yeah this connection using
specialized average case yeah I don't
know of another result so yeah so so
we're kind of looking at the the worst
average-case complexity right I don't
know other results that actually work
that way yeah so so so here's a question
I really like I mean so so I mean you
know we know that semantic monotonicity
is different from syntactic monotonicity
not only for AC 0 but also for formulas
also for circuits ok so I mean there
exists boolean functions which have
polymer which there's just monotone
boolean functions which have polynomial
size non monotone boolean circuits but
require exponential sighs monotone
circuits so there is a huge gap but so
far as I know that the known there's no
known gap in the average case with
respect to a product distribution you
can make artificial distributions where
you have a gap and I'm very tempted to
conjecture that actually there's no
guess so
you know if instead of product
distribution or it's a uniform
distribution if you say the slice
distribution so the uniform distribution
on inputs of Hamming weight exactly n
over 2 then there's no gap monotone and
non monotone complexity coincide so
there's a very curious thing so I think
it's sort of evidence that you know if
you look at the uniform distribution
which is you know morally speaking
similar to this you know slice
distribution may be monotone and I'm on
its own complexity coincide there so
that's something I've been very
interested in
thank you for this nice Oh
that's all I think it's we can split put
them on my